[Musique]
madame ouvert oui le directeur est
revenue sur sa décision
il a choisi quelqu'un d'autre vous
présenter ce qu'une blague j'ai tout
quitté pour ce boulot j'ai déménagé
scolariser mes enfants ici je suis
désolé par un pont
[Musique]
oh
j'y retrouve un travail dans une
bijouterie avec une patronne sympa d'où
vient cet argent qui glisse économie
c'est paul qui t'a donné cet argent
dis moi c'est quoi ce que fait c'est le
clip manque la tête comme ça
il doit 75000 euros
il peut pas les payer
j'ai porté plainte il ya des témoins
ayant vu un site recel vol à l'arraché
trafic de drogue cambriolage si on se ne
vous aurait pas d'accord
paul m'a dit vous travaillez dans une
bijouterie je peux pas faire ça
le haut
ça chez moi
[Musique]